[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host so June part 2 is going to be
seeing the introduction of a big villain
and throughout this video we're going to
be going through everything you need to
know about Austin Butler's fade you've
seen the original David Lynch movie then
this is the same character that sting
played but there's far more depth to him
than what we got in that though we stood
around looking like an evil Ed Sheeran
with a constant smirk on his face he
actually has deep ties with Paul and the
quiz ataretch he's such an interesting
character and it's important to bear in
mind that Fade's supposed to be pulled
up as certain more ways than one now in
looking at storytelling we often get the
idea of a doppelganger to reflect what
the hero could be had they taken a
different path the Hitchcock in doubles
something that's later at a lot of film
and these doubles act as a way where we
can compare and contrast certain
characters together on the surface
faders pull stubble and both represent
The Heirs that will eventually rule
their house one day whoever is the more
powerful out the two has been thought to
rule the galaxy and that's why there's a
lot of focus on
these two sides are clearly bitter
rivals in the June universe and that
first film centered around the
harkonnens destroying the atraelis and
taking back a racket you should call the
police for what they did eh because it
was a sting in the plan
this Feud is something that's gone back
centuries but there were plans to unite
the pair before they were even born just
like Paul fade was part of the Benny
jesuit's breeding program and if he's
still kind of getting up to speed on
June then we have some stuff that we
need to touch upon before we go further
into who the character is now the
benches are its goal at this point is to
create a Supreme Being known as the quiz
at tadarach in the June World ingesting
spice can give you certain abilities and
some can tap into the genetic memories
of their ancestors which gives them
access to a wealth of information
unfortunately the Benny Jesuit being all
women I'm not saying that unfortunately
like that it's unfortunate the women but
unfortunately by them being women it
means that they can only access the
memories on the female side and maybe
record that or I might leave it in but
with the quizzes
however with the quizzes header actually
being male this will allow them to tap
into the male side and thus they'll have
access to more information spanning tens
of thousands of years if we look at the
social structures in June you know the
women tend to be the most subservient
ones whilst the men are the leaders and
therefore being able to gain access to
this information will be far more
helpful than just being able to tap into
the women's now the Jesuit have been
carrying out the breeding program for
roughly 10 000 years with a girl almost
being complete now they've also used
religion as a way to manipulate and
control the masses and have spread the
idea this great being's coming which has
been labeled as a prophecy however
they're of course using signs to ensure
it happens so when it does they'll also
be seen as the religious figures that
people need to get behind hearing of
this prophecy has meant that people are
simply waiting for this new figure to
arrive and whoever shows up and fits the
mold they're all gonna start to follow
them and that's why so many people flock
to Paul so easily but the Benny have
their own plans in place too they see
the quiz at is being a pawn they can
place on the throne and then through him
they'll be able to control the Galaxy
they'd have to ask the emperor to do it
but he is getting old and thus they'd
have access to this unrival control and
power the first film doesn't really go
into this but there were actually
multiple people that were being groomed
to be the quiz at talarach the fact of
the matter is that Paul also wasn't
originally planned to be this person
either but the shoe ended up bidding and
thus the Benny went for it now
throughout June we often get lip service
pay to the fact that lady Jessica was
supposed to have a daughter but the Duke
wanted his son and thus she selected
this instead spice can allow one to
select the gender of their child and she
did this out of the love for the Duke
instead of going with what the order
wanted and this destroyed their plans a
bit and it also sealed the fate of the
Atreides originally the plan was to have
this daughter marry the hawk Conan's
Heir who as he guessed was going to be
fade this would unite the houses and
stop them from continuing their Feud and
it was then their child that was gonna
be the quiz that's hadaraj that's also
why he saw of an opposite to Paul as he
was originally supposed to be the Sun
that would bring them all together
however had Faith gotten power I think
that the Universe would have suffered
for it and in the new trailer we get
some brief shots of him in which he
looks extremely ruthless he probably
doesn't ever hit the thumbs up button on
videos even even though it takes two
seconds and he looks violent and vicious
in these black and white scenes a fade
was born on the planet Lanka Veil and
he's the younger brother of glossy
Rabanne who's played in the film by Dave
Batista Fade's father abelard was well
aware of how poisonous the harkona name
was and he saw that rabbana continued to
bring this dishonor in fate he'd hoped
he could write the wrongs of the past
but fade was taken by the baron whilst
reban killed their father he gained the
nickname The Bistro ban and the bound
raised Fate on gaydi Prime as an heir to
the throne now the Benny realized that
these two houses going to war would not
only be bad for the Galaxy but also bad
for their plans which are taken 10 000
years to put together realizing that if
both Paul and fate died that they lose
all the genetic material they send out a
spine moggo fenring to seduce Faye so
that a child could be born carrying on
his DNA in the film Margot will be
played by Leo said oh and we get some
black and white shots of her looking
over fade as he fights in the combat
Arena talked about this in our trailer
breakdown but I think this black and
white style actually shows that this is
all a flashback and we'll have the
blanks filled in as to what fade was up
to when everything was happening on a
rackus a Margo fell pregnant and she
gave birth to a daughter named Maria who
will touch upon briefly towards the end
of the video now in order to talk about
what happens with fade we have to get
into some heavy spoilers so yeah if you
don't want to know you don't want it
ruined then turn off now and I won't I
won't hold a grudge I promise anyway The
Baron's original plan was to have fade
marry the emperor's daughter illaran
who's played by Florence Pew in the
movie this will give the baron complete
control over the universe to them having
their quote unquote son now sat on the
throne his plan the entire time was to
gain an alliance with the emperor allow
the Australian is to take over Iraqis
kill him there and then we take the
planet and Usher in their rule the
emperor was jealous that the Israelis
were growing in popularity and that
their military strength was getting to
the point where they were too powerful
to combat now after the fall of the
Atreides the baron actually allowed the
Beast to rule over arrakis for some time
and the attorney that he brought with
him destroyed a lot of villages and
settlements this wasn't the Beast going
crazy though and they were like oh we
need to take him down the bound was well
aware that this would be the outcome of
placing him in that position of power
now he did this because when fade showed
up and was more merciful he'd seemed
like a savior and this would make people
flock to him and allow him to gain power
however they didn't count on Paul being
alive and after he became the leader of
the fremin he then starred in Uprising
Waging War on Iraqis in the har conans
he started to take the planet back which
then got the attention of the baron and
the emperor Paul stormed the capital
sort of gave a challenge of combat and
it all came to a head in the knife fight
that we see teased in the trailer fade
was chosen as the child champion and
Paul came face to face with him besting
the body in combat eventually it was
Paul who married Iran and even though
he'd been hooking up with Chaney this
wedding stopped the wall escalating
Beyond arakis now Paul would go on to
lead but it wouldn't be the big peaceful
Reign everyone hoped for and millions
were murdered in his name described as a
holy war this ravaged the Galaxy and
countless people lost their lives in
service of his new vision of what the
universe should be like caused lots of
unrest and this is where we get back to
Marie she was entrusted with
assassinating Paul but unfortunately
this ended up failing now there's lots
of complicated things going on with him
and Paul does kind of write some of the
wrongs of the past and the aftermath of
all the battles that tied in with the
whole children of June Saga in which his
kids ended up taking over the Reigns
whilst he went out into the desert and
had an Awakening sort of a big Jesus
metaphor with him returning to stop by
the Bloodshed and but it's a really
interesting story that I actually
recommend you check out now Paul's a
very flawed hero and solve the outcome
of people around him attempting to gain
power for themselves that's also the
case with fade and though they're
painting him out like a complete psycho
he was very much groomed and manipulate
as much as Paul was it's going to be
interesting to see how it all goes down
and I can't well we know because we've
spoiled it but I can't wait to see it in
live action and how it plays out in the
movie obviously let me know your
thoughts Below in the character and if
there's any other June characters you'd
like to see us cover them make sure you
let us know below if you want something
else to watch then make sure you check
out our breakdown of the trailer which
will be linked on screen right over here
got lots of things to talk about lots of
characters to break down and definitely
head over there right after this by the
way thanks for sticking to the video
I've been Paul I'll see you next time
take care peace